foreign
talk to you a little bit more okay
you said these are all your bags right
yes anything else in your pocket sir
any knives scissors any weapons Firearms
anything like that no all right have a
seat okay
[Music]
are you serious
yeah
that's interesting
[Laughter]
like he's going to washing machine
how long have you had that
really
how old are you
[Music]
do you talk to them yes
you know what there's a lot of closet
stuffed animal talkers so it's okay
everyone has to think right
all right be good to go man no way to
pack these bags up for me
foreign
[Applause]
box number 35
our main focus here in male is to
inspect cargo and shipments coming into
the country looking for items that are
being smuggled
you can go anywhere from twenty thousand
up to a hundred thousand or more Parcels
or letters a day
[Music]
I'm not sure
so let's go ahead and uh prep it for
examination the officers intercepted a
partial containing different types of
arts and crafts and further examination
revealed the frames of the paintings had
some anomalies
we're going to have to test to determine
what it is
and that's a positive test for cocaine
we're gonna notify HSI to pursue a
further investigation
it's not the powder it's become like
it's more Crystal the more powder it is
the more cut it is this package came
from Haiti destined for Riviera Beach in
Florida in between all of the paintings
a layer of cocaine within them and there
was a total of eight the total weight of
this shipment was 1.32 kilograms of
cocaine worth up to a hundred thousand
dollars in street value
so now that we have the possession of
the cocaine our goal is to identify the
recipients and dismantle the criminal
organization behind this effort here
how you doing today can I see a passport
please
anybody coming off a plane from an
international flight is a potential
suspect to us it doesn't matter how old
they are race sex where they're from
there's no textbook to show us who are
the people who swallowing drugs or
smuggling drugs
so we got to be on our toes eyes open
and listening to everything around us
because you never know when that person
we're looking for will cross your path
where you coming from five six seven or
eight please
it's a numbers game
at the end of the day the more you look
the better your chances are to find
something
gotcha
all right bye
we just got word that a bag drove over
our T8 maybe have to found some
narcotics so let's make moves man
so we'll get some details and go from
there
it could potentially be narcotics
it was an older woman traveling on a
wheelchair coming from Peru that may
have some narcotics disguise in bottles
just cut the top
I think that's the best way
it's very useful
[Music]
okay
it's cocaine
liquid cocaine's common and they put it
in normal Goods so when they come in
they just look like they're bringing
drinks for shampoo into the United
States it was cocaine in the bottle but
on top there was a little bit of liquid
if we just open a bottle and pour a
little out we would never find the
actual product so they all had it except
for this one this has nothing in it
they're hoping that CBP will stop them
and test that one
there's nothing in it and let them go
with for this case 11 other ones
about 6 900 grams
six kilos is a lot of liquid cocaine
but the passenger was 82 years old in a
wheelchair
she was very cool gave off the air that
she had done this before and nothing was
wrong
the next thing we did was contact HSI
and HSI sent a few agents over to begin
the process of interrogating her
way
what did you think it was
CBP they found eight little hand
paintings about 12 by 12 and inside the
hand paintings were packages of cocaine
about 1.32 keys so we are going to
attempt a controlled delivery on that to
the receiving address the address comes
back to a compound basically and I want
to pass out some photos of this place uh
aerial view basically there's two
structures one is an actual Church
up for sale right now they're not
worshiping any the other is a two-story
building it appears that it there is
nobody there so it's probably just a
drop location
as soon as we give the green light he's
going to go into the church compound
with the Box we just want to make sure
we've got all these corners covered we
don't know what's going to happen so
we're just gonna be prepared for
everything
safety is Paramount especially because
of the location and what we know of the
sketchy area right across the street so
we'll get fully tacked out
in the course of conducting our law
enforcement operation we run into a
number of risks
we're obviously dealing with over a
kilogram of cocaine and as such the
individuals that we're dealing with
normally have a criminal history and a
lighting one too
these individuals might use guns to
protect themselves protect the product
so we have to take every precaution to
make sure that we protect the community
and obviously our fellow law enforcement
officials
all right radio kick we're going to be
setting up here
I've been assigned to this office in
West Palm Beach Florida for three years
what we're seeing today is pretty common
here in South Florida our communities
seeing a lot of cocaine so we want to
make sure that we take these drugs off
the street
our ultimate game plan is obviously to
this rock or dismantle the organization
that's operating out of Palm Beach
County here in Florida
[Music]
air unit status
there are several Brown units looking at
the location and also we have an
aircraft unit that is assisting us
foreign
air units so that we don't have to get
as close and burn the operation and
especially in areas like where we're at
there's a lot of shootings here there's
a lot of drug activity in fact the
Target location is literally sitting
across the street from known drug
traffickers
our Target location so
we're clear I think everyone's in
position we can commence the operation
whenever you're ready
to deliver the parcel to him
all right all you're I am sending in the
package
you see the protein Target now
unit do you have visual on the package
standby
shirt
okay with a blue shirt
so we have reached a critical point in
our investigation this package has been
claimed by somebody
there's a very big possibility we're
going to be going mobile that this
package is going to be delivered to
someone else the ultimate distributor
yeah
but they're pulling out now
ladies and gentlemen we're about to go
mobile
all right
I'm at the apartments just to the north
of Virginia taking a parking lot
we need to get somebody back there the
eyeball is just in case even out of the
vehicle and already walked into an
apartment I'm close by
it's kind of parked by some containers
yep he's right here he's right there so
here's the vehicle to our right
there's a subject inside the vehicle yes
he is
he's in it with it
someone's gonna walk up quickly and grab
that package
[Music]
what did you think it was
in Peru is vitamins
natural remedies
they don't sell it in pharmacies okay so
who did you talk to
BF Diaz okay
so Diaz comes to your house knocks on
your door and says hey can you take
something to me and you said yes
so anytime person give me your phone
number okay
okay
you don't know who gave them your phone
number to Diaz
she stated that she received a phone
call from an individual she didn't know
the individual that well a friend of a
friend you don't know him okay
is
first time
you think that's kind of
kind of shady
today
she said that she did not know she was
smuggling cocaine people tell us this
stuff all the time but it's our job to
investigate the truth find out who this
individual is or if this individual even
exists
[Music]
vehicle has not backed up
walking towards the Mercedes
okay it looks like a guy
[Music]
yeah yeah
walking towards the apartment
all right we got it we got it we got the
package right here
two males one with a blue shirt one with
the gray shirt
and they're walking to one of the
apartment complexes we're gonna take
them down yeah man
we're gonna get down come on over guys
are we approaching yes approach
all right guys going going
[Music]
thank you
back in the apartment
open
[Music]
good morning
[Applause]
you could have gone anywhere
you're on the first floor
upstairs no downstairs
repeating they are on the first floor we
need backup
s
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
keep walking keep walking stop right
there
hands up hands up let's go
and you've got snare coming out we got
one
we have two individuals in custody with
approximately 1.32 kilos of cocaine
Street values about a hundred thousand
dollars U.S
they're looking at possession with
intent to distribute we have a secure
site we're still processing doing a
search warrant now on the apartment and
the vehicle
it's got some receipts to Haiti
putting people in jail is fine taking
drugs off the street is fantastic but
there's a ton of kids here so it makes
you feel even better when you take down
people that are doing this kind of thing
in this atmosphere
oh
[Music]
the investigation does it stop here we
will continue doing analysis or
telephone records and any other evidence
that we've got from search forms we
started at the beginning with just a
very simple package and now we have
enough evidence to be able to Target a
transnational criminal organization
[Music]
thank you
this is your last opportunity
otherwise you're done and Diaz is just
gonna go through
okay where New York okay in New York
where in New York it's a big place
he works in trucks so electrophes
he's a truck driver
doesn't know which company
she never stated that she had knowledge
that she was smuggling in cocaine but we
got a lot of information from her about
this individual who wanted the bottles
that she was bringing back so we're
gonna have to follow up and see where it
leads any facial hair let's fish
anytime that we get a seizure like this
it's a good feeling this is our job it's
to stop these narcotics from coming into
the United States
but it doesn't stop here for us our job
is to investigate these crimes
transnationally
and prosecute these criminal
organizations from the top down
to know that we stopped this load of
Narcotics coming into the U.S that could
have ended up into some kids nose and
some kids arms on the streets it's a
rush it really is
you're never winning the war but we do
like to win those individual battles
from time to time
[Music]